wer kann in der ample am besten rechnen
her was würden Sie sagen also
WN ja also ich merke ich war in Matthe
so
okay ich am Ende ja ich habe am Ende
wirtschaftswisenschaften studiert und
dann wurd es ein bisschen besser weil
ich da auch gefordert wurde im Studium
also mat ist wichtig kann ich im
Nachhinein sagen ansonsten muss ich
gestehen chrisner ist ein ziemlich
schneller Rechner ja ja schneller als
ich im Rechnen auch im Kopf rechnen aber
die ganze Ampel hat sich ja katastrophal
verrechnet auch in einem metaphorischen
Sinn möchte ich mal sagen dann sollten
wir jetzt konkret werden Herr Lanz oder
wir sollten konkret werden wie konnte
das passieren das ist die konkrete Frage
oder anders gefragt was zum Teufel haben
sie sich dabei gedacht ja im nach ich
will das sehr offen einräumen im
Nachhinein ähm ärgere ich mich und im
Nachinein muss man sagen es war ein
Fehler eine buchungspraxis fortzusetzen
die Länder und Bund angefangen hatten
ähm von der wir gesagt haben okay das
ist Teil des Kompromisses dieser
Koalition und gleichzeitig sehen sie ja
an der Betroffenheit jetzt auchm auch
die Länderhaushalte schliäßig holzstein
NRW und andere die große Herausforderung
jetzt haben wichtig ist glaube ich eins
dass man unterscheidet zwischen dem was
da falsch gelaufen ist bei der
buchungspraxis
nämlich die Möglichkeit Kredite die
genehmigt waren in andere Haushaltsjahre
zu übertragen und dann die Trickserei
die und der ja und das ist wie gesagt
das ist leider eine eine Praxis die wir
von der groko seiner Zeit erbt und das
ärgert mich h nachern dass wir diesen
Punkt übernommen haben der Punkt ist her
landz mit allen anderen dken aus Zeiten
der Gru und sie zitierten mich ja
eingangs hier auch was mich damals
geärgert hat das war ja die
Oppositionszeit der FDP als S das im
Haushaltsausschuss war als da Milliarden
für alles mögliche ausgegeben wurden
aber sind do immer noch die Opposition
sind sie immer no GZ ich zu wenn ich
ganz kurz wenn ich ganz kurz den Satz zu
Ende führen darf g W die da hat mich
tierisch geärgert dass da Milliarden
ausgegeben worden sind mit der
Begründung die mit Corona seiner Zeit
nicht zu tun hatte so etwas haben haben
wir nie gemacht in dieser
Bundesregierung zum Glück die
buchungspraxis war ein Fehler und jetzt
kommt die gute Nachricht
glücklicherweise und das ist neben der
buchungspraxis wahrscheinlich für die
Menschen in Deutschland das
entscheidende die Schuldenquote also die
Verschuldung des Bundes geht zurück wir
haben knapp 70% Staatsschulden geerbt
als wir angetreten sind und werden im
kommenden Jahr bei unter 65% sein das
heißt weniger Schulden zum Glück in der
Realität aber die buchungspraxis war ein
Fehler okay dann schon mal um die die
entscheidenden Eckdaten zu klären
es wird die Schuldenbremse eingehalten
mit ihnen in der Regierung mit der FDP
das ist safe ja das die die
Schuldenbremse natürlich und
aufgeweicht ich höre ja die Stimmen von
vielen CDU Ministerpräsidenten
beispielsweise die sehr deutlich sagen
also mittlerweile sind es glaube ich
fast alle ich sage immer außer Markus
Söder wobei der in 2022 und 21 auch die
Schuldenbremse mal ausweiten ausweichen
wollte aufweichen wollte das hielte ich
für einen katastrophalen Fehler die
Schuldenbremse ist ein Erfolgsmodell und
ich sage sie sowas wie eine
Lebensversicherung auch für die
Steuerzahler und gerade in Schwierigkeit
schwierigen Zeiten kündigt meine seine
Lebensversicherung nicht also die
Schuldenbremse wird nicht gekündigt
aufgekündigt und Steuererhöhungen gibt's
auch keine also es gibt Deutschland ist
ein höchsteuerland und neue Steuern zu
erfinden und Steuern zu erhöhen wäre das
absolut falsche Signal nein okay und
ihnen fehlen jetzt 17 Milliarden für den
kommenden Haushalt sind es 17 Milliarden
Euro über die jetzt gerade gesprochen
wird innerhalb der Koalition und jetzt
kurz um die Dimension deutlich zu machen
17 Milliarden unfassbar viel Geld der
Bundeshaushalt hat ein Volumen von etwa
450 Milliarden fast eine halbe Billion
genau und der Gesamtstaat also man noch
Länder und Kommunen dazu zieht die
Länder sollen ja auch Geld für Bildung
ausgeben wie wir vorhin festgestellt
haben kommen wir auf fast eine Billionen
Euro insgesamt und da sind 17 Milliarden
möglich wir haben nämlich in den letzten
zwei Jahren auch schon konsolidiert
deswegen ist die genannte Schuldenquote
in Deutschland glücklicherweise
zurückgegangen insofern muss es auch
diesmal gelingen Frau Herrmann sie sagen
alles Mist so geht das nicht wir müssen
endlich mal richtig der Kanzler würde
sagen ins doing kommen ja ich weiß gar
nicht wo ich anfangen
soll
also ja erstmal bei den 17 Milliarden
die eingespart werden müssen das ist
nicht so einfach wie her tut weil die
meisten Ausgaben im Haushalt sind ja
festgezoht also mir ist eigentlich ein
Rätsel wo sie diese 17 Milliarden
rausschneiden wollen das können sie ja
vielleicht nachher noch mal erlu jetzt
direkt oder ja soll ich ihn jetzt fragen
wie also ich weiß nicht wo die herkommen
sollen so und also und was aber noch
viel schlimmer ist ist tatsächlich diese
Idee dass die Schuldenbremse an und für
sich eine gute Idee ist denn
damit verspielt Deutschland seine
Zukunft denn man muss sich klar machen
dass man Investitionen nur finanzieren
kann wenn man Schulden macht ohne
Schulden gibt es keine Investitionen und
ohne Investitionen gibt es keine zu
Zukunft dannil ist doch klar das was ich
jetzt ausgebe um jetzt zu investieren
das ist dann praktisch äh der Ertrag von
morgen und wir haben ganz große Probleme
die wir dringend angehen müssen also
beispielsweise eben den Klimaschutz und
wenn man dann einfach sagt Geld gibt es
nicht äh dann ja ich dann ist ist es für
mich ganz schlimm zu sehen dass ein
reiches Land wie Deutschland
äh nicht in der Lage ist politisch zu
gestalten weil man nun ausgerechnet an
die schulldenbremse glaubt ähm ja für
sie ist das sozusagen so ein eine
Ideologie schuldentaliban nennen sie
genau also ich hab ich muss zugeben dass
ich gewisses Mitleid mit Christian
Lindner habe weil das ist aus ihrem Mund
ist das eine große Sache ja das ist aber
es ist so weil er eben in seiner
Fraktion und auch in der Partei hat er
sehr
viele Leute
die mit aller Kraft ihres Herzens an der
an die Schuldenbremse glauben das ist
für die sozusagen der neue Jesus und
da und die es gibt ja auch eine Basis
Initiative die sagt raus aus der Ampel
weil man das Gefühl hat dass man diese
Schuldenbremse schon zu sag zu stark
aufgeweicht hat aber das ändert nichts
daran dass man in die Zukunft nur
investieren kann wenn man Schulden macht
also diese Idee Schulden sind böse die
ist einfach grundfalsch warum sind
Schulden nicht böse ganz kurz noch Frau
Hermann ichch mal verstehen ja also die
Leute haben ja immer das Kote von
Entschuldigung 66% 66% die USA sind bei
120% sind die USA zusammengebrochen
nein nein nein das sind rein politische
Spielchen der Republikaner die USA
selber wachsen viel stärker als
Deutschland Frankreich Japan
Großbritannien alle Länder haben sehr
viel höhere Schulden als Deutschland
kein Land ist zusammengebrochen und das
Land das am stärksten an der
Schuldenbremse oder an der Idee hängt
bloß keine Schulden machen nämlich
Deutschland ist jetzt sozusagen das
Schlusslicht in ganz Europa wächst nicht
schrumpft werden alle anderen Länder
wächsen weil sie nämlich nicht diese
Idee haben man darf auf gar kein Fall
Geld ausgeben und vielleicht jetzt noch
mal diese Frage warum muss man äh
Schulden machen um zu investieren die
Idee bei der FDP ist ja ich soll ich
kann nur investieren indem ich vorher
spare also irgendwo Kürze und dann äh
erstmal ein also so ein bisschen wie ein
äh wie soll man sagen wie ein
Eichhörnchen nicht also erstmal werden
die Nüsse zusammengesammelt und dann
werden sie wieder ausgegeben so aber das
Problem ist wenn ich jetzt erstmal Kürze
dann fehlt ja Nachfrage in der
Wirtschaft das heißt man hat
man macht vorsätzlich produziert man
eine Krise und dann investiert aber
niemand mehr weil man ja in der Krise
ist das heißt wenn man
ähäh friktionslos oder problemlos
wachsen will und investieren will dann
muss man das über die Schulden machen
und vielleicht ein Argument dass jetzt
doch Friedrich Merz und auch Christian
Lindner überzeugen könnte wenn man sich
fragt wie kann das sein dass Angela
Merkel 16 Jahre Kanzlerin war dann liegt
es daran dass sie nie gespart hat so
schlau war Angela Merkel nämlich so und
da würde ich jetzt mal hoffen dass die
Ampel die ja auch das Ziel hat 16 Jahre
zu regieren sich Malin Beispiel an
Angela Merkel nimmt also das ist ein
Grund war sind noch ganz kurz um zulären
sie sind von der FDP aber so viel
Leidenschaft ja für Kapitalismus
entfesselten Kapital ich selten gehört
von Frau Hermann
jetztin her nein nein Frau Hermann hätte
recht Frau Hermann hätte recht wenn wir
eine zentrale verwaltungswirtschaft
hätten also Planwirtschaft dann würde
das absolut Sinn ergeben
glücklicherweise glücklicherweise ich
komme gleich zu den Vereinigten Staaten
Frau Herrmann glücklicherweise sind wir
das nicht und jetzt will ich eins
vereststellen ja der Staat muss
investieren z.B in seine Infrastruktur
und die gute Nachricht ist wir tun das
die Investitionsquote also der Anteil am
Haushalt wo wir echt investieren in die
Infrastruktur beispielsweise in die
Autobahn äh und so weiter und so fort äh
da geht die Investitionsquote seit dem
chrisner Finanzminister ist nach oben
also der Anteil der Investition am
Bundeshaushalt ist nach oben
gegangen aber die die Investitionsquote
zurzeit jetzt erwischen mich auf dem
kalten Fuß ich habe sie gerade nicht ich
kann ganz viele Zahlen aber die habe ich
jetzt spontan nicht parat und dann hätte
ich noch eine
Frage sind denn die Nettoinvestitionen
positiv also es bringt ja nichts wenn
manan das spannend dass Sie das sagen
weil genau auf den Punkt möchte ich
jetzt gerade
hinaus ne von 10 €os in Deutschland
werden von der Privatwirtschaft
investiert und ich glaube dass all das
was sie meinen sie meinen ja Investition
in neue Technologien beispielsweise neue
Anlagen und so weiter die man dann
wiederum abschreibt das ja die Idee
dahinter das macht die Privatwirtschaft
richtigerweise und der Staat investiert
klugerweise in seine Infrastruktur damit
auf dieser Infrastruktur eine gute
Marktwirtschaft entstehen kann also das
Wichtigste ist und da muss man jetzt den
Blick ein bisschen weiter nehmen weil
sie die USA als als Beispiel genommen
haben die deutsche Staatsverschuldung
mit zurzeit 66% glücklicherweise fallen
wie viel Geld ist das ungefähr das wir
haben ungefhr 1 Billion um den Dreh
Schulden ja das ist die das ist aber das
ist aber das ist aber nicht die ganze
Nachricht die jetzt wird's ein bisschen
schlechter jetzt wird's ein bisschen
schlechter wir haben das Problem dass
wir einerseits die direkte
Staatsverschuldung haben das sind die
vorin genannten 66% vom Brutto
Inlandsprodukt und auf der anderen Seite
haben wir eine indirekte
Staatsverschuldung das ist die
versteckte Staatsverschuldung in den
sozialen Sicherungssystem die wir haben
und wenn wir die mit dazu rechnen würden
Frau Hermann dann liegen wir bei einer
Schuldenquote je nach Rechenbeispiel es
gibt unterschiedliche das gebe ich zu
liegen bei einer Schuldenquote von eher
160 170%. und dieser Blick und da müsste
man es jetzt mit den USA vergleichen ist
ein besonders ein besonderer auf
Deutschland weil die Vereinigten Staaten
gerade in ihren Sicherungssystem haben
das heißt Ansprüche zukünftiger
Generation äh dass diese Dinge meistens
in den USA Kapital gedeckt und bereits
finanziert sind und das ist in
Deutschland anders deswegen warne ich
davor sich nur auf die direkte
Staatsverschuldung zu konzentrieren
sondern wir müssen glaube ich auch
die die verichtung Z hab die haben wir
bis heute schon im Bundeshaushalt der
Bundeshaushalt hat einen vollkommen
nachvollziehbaren und auch gesetzlich
richtigen Zuschuss in die gesetzliche
rettenversicherung von 117 Milliarden
Euro im kommenden Jahr der Hintergrund
ist dass die die Rentenversicherung
nicht ausreichend Beiträge hat um die
Berechtigten Ansprüche der Generation zu
bedienen die das Land groß gemacht haben
und diese demografische Situation die
muss man im Hinterkopf haben wenn man
auch über die Schuldenbremse diskutiert
und noch mal dass der Staat der Zentrale
Investor ist und damit die Wirtschaft
nach vorne bringt das funktioniert in
einer Marktwirtschaft nicht denn die
privaten Unternehmen sind immer besser
in der Lage sehr zielgerichtet zu
investieren das ma eine frage es geht
doch um die Zukunft dieses Landes wir
investieren aber vor allen Dingen
wenn man so will in die Vergangenheit
wir investieren irsinnig viel Geld in
Rente beispielsweise das ist nicht
unbedingt in die Zukunft gerichtet ja
deswegen noch mal die Frage wenn wir das
mit Abstand der größte Posten Arbeit und
Soziales in diesem Bundeshaushalt 120
Milliarden glaube ich gehen nur in die
Rente 117 im kommenden Jahr ungefähr 50%
ist der Anteil Arbeit und sozial die
Rente noch mal die Frage wie viel ist
echtes Investment was investieren wir
wirklich in Infrastruktur in Eisenbahn
in Brücken in Digitalisierung in all die
Dinge die wichtig sind wie viel Summe
also die die Summe ich habe sehen Sie es
mir nachher LZ ich habe die genaauo mit
wir sind jetzt auch gerade bei dem
Bundeshaushalt 24 neu zu beraten wie Sie
wissen ich kann ih aus dem Kopf jetzt
leider nicht sagen die exakte die exakte
ja die exakte Summe habe ich jetzt sehen
Sie es mir bitte nach so ehrlich muss
man sein habe ich jetzt nicht im Kopf
aber wir haben ich hab es doch jetzt
schon gesagt oder also veren
mit zuk das Problem ich will DAF hinaus
herrz das Problem ist bei dieser
sogenannten bei diesen Investitionen des
Staates haben wir die Situation dass
anders als private Wirtschaftssubjekte
die investieren eine Summe dann
schreiben Sie sie über verschiedene
Wirtschaftsjahre ab haben wir bei den
investi des Staates ja solche
Investition die sich klassischerweise
nicht abschreiben lassen weil sie gar
kein Return on Investment bringen also
eine Autobahn beispielsweise natürlich
haben wir gewisse Mauteinnahmen aber das
ist nicht der zentrale Punkt das ist ein
Gesamtbeitrag um die Wirtschaft
funktionieren zu lassen deswegen ist es
ein bisschen schwer die Frage so zu
stellen wie Frau Hermann sie gerade
beantwortet hat denn das unterstellt
dass der Staat sozusagen der Zentrale
Planer ist und quasi anstatt der
Wirtschaftssubjekte das Geld ausgibt das
macht relativ wenig noch mal ganz kurz
dazu was sagen also erstens zum Thema
Rente ich habe das extra vorher nachgegu
hat ihr Spickzettel
dabei also der ja hilft immer also ich
habe das extra vorher nachgeguckt
Durchschnittsrente in Deutschland ist
netto
1384 € im Monat ich würde mal sagen da
kann man nicht sparen weil
der genau also aber wie immer die
staatlichen Zuschüsse sind man kann bei
der Rente nicht sparen weil die Rente
schon sehr niedrig ist und man muss
einfach sehen dass es sehr viele
versicherungsfremde Leistungen in der
Rente gibt die mit den Angestellten und
ihren Rentenansprüchen nichts zu tun
haben ich sage nur als ein Beispiel die
mütterrente so das nächste ist dass das
was
Herr eben erzählt hat nämlich dass
Deutschland nur eine Billion Schulden
hat nicht stimmt kann man leicht rechnen
die Wirtschaftsleistung in Deutschland
liegt bei ungefähr 4 Billionen Euro da 4
Billionen ja das ist die Wirtschaft das
ist die Wirtschaftsleistung davon 66%
sind natürlich viel mehr als eine
Billion und dann finde ich würde ich
jetzt noch mal gerne auf die Sachen
kommen um die es konkret geht also weil
das ja so ein bisschen gewabbert hat was
ist ja eigentlich jetzt eine Inflation
und worum geht's in der Zukunft also die
60 Milliarden die jetzt fehlen durch das
verfassungsgsurte Teil sind ja unter
anderem die Sanierung für die Bahn das
sind die schipfabriken in Magdeburg und
Dresden Intel und tscm oder wie die
heißen a ah ja genau aus Taiwan also da
das ist eine strategische Idee von
gesamt Europa zu sagen wir wollen nicht
mehr von China und Taiwan abhängig sein
und dann geht es natürlich um solche
Sachen wie Klimaschutz in der Industrie
wenn man grünen Stahl grüne Chemie haben
will dann ist das eben sehr viel teurer
als fossile Chemie und diese Differenz
müssen die Firmen erstattet bekommen
sonst können sie da nicht investieren
das heißt es geht alles es geht um sehr
zentrale Zukunftsprojekte und es gäbe
überhaupt gar kein Problem äh zu sagen
äh dass es eigentlich sinnvoll äh dafür
Geld auszugeben und das ist ja
interessant dass inzwischen eben auch
schon sehr viele cdula äh das erkannt
haben und dass es hier um die Zukunft
von Deutschland geht okay also ich muss
mich jetzt korrigeren das sind 1,4
Billionen etwa 1,45 wenn ich jetzt
richtig in Erinnerung habe äh haben sie
recht sry muss immer noch mehr sein sind
das nicht 66% dass ich die Zahl jetzt
vor nicht nicht exakt dieser Studie 2.0
erlebe ich hier
gerade sie do gerade aus ja also es müss
noch ungefähr 2,5 Billionen sein oder
ich meine 2 24
sor ist nicht egal dafür muss ich mich
auch entschuldigen dass ich die Zahl
jetzt nicht parat
hatte Haushaltsausschuss sie haben viel
zu ich bin nicht im
haushalsausschuss pulper mich unumwunden
ein die hätte ich ganz kurz eine kurze
Frage weil wir gleich zu Christopher
klar kommen ich wir sind auf der Jagd
nach 17 Milliarden ne 60 Milliarden s
insgesamt aber pro Jahr ungefähr es geht
ja um vier Jahre das zeigt aber dass die
Dimension nicht so riesig ist aber es
geht um 17 Milliarden genau und jetzt
folgender Vorschlag also wir haben auch
mal gerechnet sehr findige Kollegen die
sagten und ich frage mich ob sie
mitgehen würden Abschaffung
dieselprivileg mit ihnen zu machen würde
8 Milliarden nein Herr Herr Lanz ich
werde jetzt nein ich werde jetzt nicht
den Markt der Möglichkeiten aus ausrufen
sondern das Mus nein das muss aber ich
weiß jourtisches Interesse gibt aber das
das muss finde ich innerhalb der
Koalition besprochen werden ich werde
jetzt nicht einzelne Posten sagen Ja
oder Nein sondern wir reden gerade
wirklich sehr ernsthaft darüber aber ist
das etwas was sie ausschließt ich bin
jetzt nicht an dem Punkt wo ich hier
Dinge ausschließe oder dazuage dass sie
kommen oder nicht kommen Herr LZ sondern
ich bin an Punkt schließen nicht aus das
finde ich schon gut damit bin ich schon
zufrieden Herr bin heute Bescheid
das sind Sie immer das schätze ich auch
sehr an aber um es noch mal auf Punkt zu
bringen ich werde jetzt nicht über
einzelne Post reden wo man sagt das
machen wir das machen wir nicht darüber
reden wir in der MA ich das für sie wir
hten noch die Entfernungspauschale z.B
die
nurleruschale haben wir gerade
richtigerweise erhöht weil auch die
Kosten für die arbeitehmer aber WN man
sagen würde die bezahlen wir sozusagen
nur noch den unteren
30% der einkommensbezieh also Leute die
es wirklich brauchen und nicht g
kannenmäßig sozusagen an alle würde 4
Milliarden bringen wären sie dabei ich
überlege gerade ob die Rechnung wir sind
jetzt ja richtigerweise mathematisch
korrekt Hermann wacht ja ich ich merke
das und ärger mich bei mich selbst
gerade ein bisschen dass ich das vor
nicht parat hatte sie können bitte
wirklich sie haben so viel Zeug im Kopf
m nicht gut aber das ärgert ein dann
schon wenn man eine Zahl nicht parat hat
die man eigentlich hätte haben müssen D
ich ein FDPler hier so selber geiselt in
der Sendung habe ich lange nicht Erb GI
es gibt auch auch immer Grund zur selbst
viele Zahlen habe ich übrigens MTE ich
übrigens dass dass
Christian Lindner gesagt hat dieser
Haushalt dieser Verfassungs
äh Bruch da der ist peinlich das war ich
gut das einfach mal so sagt so
Abschaffung
Dienstwagenprivileg ich kann ihn dazu
gerne etwas sagen das sogenannte
Dienstwagenprivileg wenn man es in
Anführungszeichen abschaffen würde also
die dienstwagenbeschweuung hieße ja dass
dann jeder der ein Dienstwagen benutzt
weil er beispielsweise viel Außendienst
hat dass er dann einzeln abrechnen würde
auch mit dem Finanzamt dann
möglicherweise und wir hätten also
tausende Hunderttausende von
fatenbüchern die wir führen müssen ob
das eine kluge Idee ist das sind ja
keine Geschenke an die Steuerzahler
sondern es ist eine Vereinfachung einer
abrechnungsm ne ich glaube das ist auch
anders es geht nicht darum das
Dienstwagenprivileg abzuschaffen sondern
das Problem ist dass der Steuersatz zu
niedrig ist und man müsste den damit es
angemessen besteuert wird müsste man den
Steuersatz verdoppeln und dadurch kämen
dann die 5 Milliarden zust verstehe das
wäre das wäre die Idee 5 Milliarden okay
und äh Umwelt Ministerium glaube ich
schöner Vorschlag sie äh erhöhen die
Mehrwertsteuer aber nur für tierische
Lebensmittel Pflanzen gehen weiterhin so
durch Salat Paprika also mein Eindruck
ist dass das deutsche
Mehrwertsteuersystem nicht an
unterkomplexität leidet deswegen der
mein Vorschlag jetzt ist nicht noch
komplizierter zu machen okay okay also
würden sie nicht
machen ich habe ja gerade gesagt ich
öffne nicht der Mark der Möglichkeiten
aber der aber den Vorschlag hatte ich
bisher auch so konkret
nein das ma keinen Sinn sind sie auch
Malm überrascht ne wie kreativ wie
kreativ ihre Kollegen auch sind alles
gut ich höre täglich kreative Dinge ich
kann es mir vorstellen und Bürgergeld
kürzen schließen sie aus zum Schluss
also ich habe ja gesagt wir müssen uns
überlegen wie die Berechnungsmethode ist
denn wir haben jetzt eine aktuelle
Studie in den kommenden Tagen wohl ist
jetzt auch l öffentlich geworden über
die Frage des lohnabstandsgebots also
lohnt es sich zu arbeiten und das ist
zentral mir geht es beim Bürgergeld vor
allen Ding um die sogenannten
zufdienstgrenzen das heißt wenn jemand
sich aus dem Bürgergeld herausarbeitet
dass er von dem was er oder sie verdient
mehr hat in Zukunft da haben wir schon
Dinge besser gemacht von hatzf zu
Bürgergeld aber ich glaube da können wir
noch besser werden und schauen uns diese
Ergebnisse genau an also man muss ganz
klar sehen äh nein man muss ganz klar
sehen dass man am Bürgergeld gar nichts
machen kann weil die Auszahlung läuft
schon für das Jahr
2024 also da ist kann man gar nicht mehr
kürzen und äh aßdem ist wenn man sagt
Lohnabstandsgebot dann ist ja mal die
Frage wo ist eigentlich das Problem ist
das Bürgergeld so hoch oder aber ist es
und das wir meine These der Mindestlohn
nicht viel zu niedrig also Mindestlohn
wurde eingeführt oder
2022 auf 12 € festgesetzt und seitdem
wurde er nur um 41 Cent erhöht das sind
3% obwohl inzwischen die Inflation bei
13 % lag das heißt man muss einfach
sagen es ist ein absoluter Skandal wie
niedrig der Mindestlohn ist und selbst
die CDA also die der Arbeitnehmerflügel
der CDU sagt ja das muss der Mindestlohn
muss 14 € betragen und wenn man den
Mindestlohn hoch setzen würde dann hätte
man auch gar kein Problem mit dem
Lohnabstand also ich will Z zur
Vervollständigung des Bildes von Frau
Hermann ganz kurz nur sagen also wir
haben jedenfalls im Vergleich äh auch zu
den Durchschnittseinkommen in Europa
einen relativ hohen Mindestlohn bereits
heute erstens und zweitens entwickelt
sicher gerade nicht anhand der Inflation
sondern Anh der Lohnentwicklung was auch
Sinn macht weil er ja ein Lohn ist der
Mindestlohn und deswegen halte ich es
für unklug da wieder in die Lohnfindung
einzugreifen das macht eine Kommission
richtigerweise und die ist
unabhängig